There’s going to be a miles
Morales live action
And I think they're probably more concerned with me
being like Prowler and that or something like that.
I'm too old to be Spider-Man now.
Like, Spider-Man can't have like,
you know. I don't know.
That could be interesting.
Only if he dies or something like that.
Yeah, it can't be like, you know, talking about like,
I need to roll out my
IT bands, you had a cameo in Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse
Do you think that this was Sony's way of apologizing
for not casting you as Spider-Man? no.
I don't think they even thought about it
Welcome back everyone, It's Charlie
Donald Glover very nonchalantly confirmed Marvel
and Sony's plans to do a live action Miles
Morales Movie and bring him back is the same live
action prowler from the MCU that we saw him play
during Spider-Man Across The Spider-Verse
just last year as part of their larger plan
to connect everything that Sony is doing
with his Spider-Man movies
in everything Marvel is doing with its Tom Holland's
Spider-Man in the MCU.
So we'll break it all down because we did learn way
more about
what's actually going on with Spider-Man
four behind the scenes.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big Super Bowl trailers
coming this week.
The Deadpool three trailer is supposed to come.
Of course,
I will do videos for as many of them as possible.
but the big news you probably saw, Donald Glover
just confirms some things that the marvel in the Sony
people said last year after the premiere of Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse.
So at the time, Amy Pascal, who's Sony's main producer
on all the main Spider-Man movies,
not every Spider-Man movie,
but like the Tom Holland Marvel Spider-Man movies.
she was the main producer on all the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man movies, the Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man movies.
she's the main Sony person
on all the Spider-Verse movies, too.
But she's not really involved with the Venom movies
or the Kraven movie.
The Morbius movie. The Madame Web movie.
Like all those other spin off movies
that Sony is doing set in the Spider-Man
Venom universe,
like a totally separate group inside Sony.
Avi A-Rod, who is also working on the Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man movies way back in the day,
he's the person that's involved
with those other Spider-Man spin off movies.
but at the Spider-Verse premiere last year, Amy Pascal,
who typically says a lot
that she probably shouldn't be talking about,
so that they were developing a live action Miles
Morales movie alongside Tom Holland's Spider-Man four
and the Beyond the Spider-Verse movie.
There've been a couple of really solid live
action Miles Morales fan
films out there to the past several years.
she didn't offer too many details on
when that Live-Action Miles Morales movie would happen
and how it would connect with Spider-Man four
in the Spider-Verse movies.
because Donald Glover talks
about how they'll bring him back as his live
action version of the Prowler that we just saw.
That prowler is actually the same one
that he played in the MCU Spider-Man homecoming movie.
He didn't have any special powers
like other versions of The Prowler.
He just had the tech suit
in the idea with the Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse cameo
was that he had ended up in another universe
outside the MCU.
Somehow, probably the same with the Vulture
wound up in the Venom
universe
because of Doctor Strange's in Spider-Man spell.
That first time.
And that's why Spider Gwen and Holby Brown
Spider Punk had captured
him, brought him to their spider force base
and he was waiting in his cell to be sent back
to the MCU universe because that was the whole point
of them all being in the cells there.
They were being sent back to their original universes.
that scene was meant to pay off.
The evolution of his MCU prowler from Spider-Man
Homecoming.
During that movie,
he had just started to buy the tech from Vulture
to make his prowler suit,
but he hadn't started using the actual suit yet.
cut to several years later in the MCU
because we have Avengers Infinity War, the snapped,
the five year time jump, Avengers Endgame, the Blip,
and at some point he became the full comic book prowler
during Spider-Man homecoming, there was a deleted scene
where he specifically references the Miles Morales
of the MCU, who at the time was very young
and had not gotten his spider bite yet.
after the movies
several years ago,
everyone kept asking Kevin Feige, Tom Holland,
when they'd introduced that version of Miles
Morales in the MCU, like, he's right there.
He exists already.
When are we going to actually see him?
Kevin Feige has typically always said the same thing.
He usually just deflects to the Spider-Verse movies,
saying that we had this
amazing Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse coming out pretty soon.
We'll focus on that right now.
basically
just trying to avoid talking about live action.
Miles Morales in the MCU, Tom Holland though
does not have this problem like typical spoiler Brose.
In the past he's revealed that there have been plans
to do live action.
Miles Morales At some point.
Thank you very much.
Spoiler bro's another mission accomplished.
he didn't say exactly when that live action Miles
Morales is going to happen.
But since Amy Pascal said that they were developing
a live action Miles Morales spin off movie last year,
my only theory right now, just based on
what everybody is saying between Marvel and Sony,
is that they're waiting until after Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse comes out in theaters
to introduce live action
Miles Morales in is probably part of their larger plan
to cross over the animated spider-verse characters
into the live action movies heading into Secret Wars.
So here's the deal.
They had a little bit of live action
crossover and Spider-Man across the spider-verse
like Donald Glover's prowler from the MCU is live
action mixed with the animated Spider-Verse characters.
they did the same thing with the Venom characters, too.
Like he peeks his head into the Venom universe
in their live action, but he's animated Lord.
And Miller said that there were actually longer
live action blended scenes with live action characters
and animated characters,
but it got a little too crazy and they wanted to save
some of that stuff for Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse to try and perfect it,
I think they're using that to test out their ability
to actually blend those two types of elements together
so that it doesn't look too ridiculous
by the time we get to Avengers Secret Wars
so that they can actually cameo that version of Miles
Morales, Spider Gwen in Spider-Man
29 and maybe other characters
from the Spider-Verse movies in Secret Wars.
they even had a brief Easter egg for Miles Morales
during Spider-Man,
far from home between Jamie Foxx's
Electro and Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man
So what they would
logically do is just wait till after that
to actually do their live action Miles
Morales movie or their version of live action
Miles Morales in the Tom Holland's Spider-Man movies.
because it sounds like they would actually cameo him
in one of Tom Holland's Spider-Man
sequels, like Spider-Man four or five or six,
whichever one it winds up being.
then he'd go on to his solo movies.
Shameik Moore, who is the voice of animated
Miles Morales in all the Spider-Verse movies,
has been asked about this a couple of different times,
especially last year when the movie came out.
he's been campaigning to have Sony
cast him as that Live-Action
Miles Morales my assumption right now
is he probably won't wind up winning that role.
It'll probably go to a younger actor
so they can just have a much longer career.
Same way Tom Holland was cast when he was very,
very young.
I think Marvel and Sony want to keep their options open
if they want to do a version of live action.
Miles Morales This from another universe
like the MCU version
instead of the Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse version.
but essentially, Sony has been wanting a live action
version of Spider-Man to be in all their Spider-Man
spin off movies like there were all those Easter eggs
in the morbius Post-Credits scene in the Morbius
trailer with different versions of Spider-Man
Easter eggs from Tobey Maguire,
Andrew Garfield's Universe
from Tom Holland's Spider-Man movies.
if they want to start using a version of Spider-Man
in their movies so badly,
they can actually just use a live action.
Miles Morales Eventually, once they introduce him, end,
they can bring back Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man
or Tobey Maguire Spider-Man to be the older Spider-Man
mentor to his younger Spider-Man side note.
Please do not kill one of them off
in service of that Miles Morales origin story.
It's funny that Donald Glover
actually referenced that like you have.
Sony wanted to bring me back as Spider-Man.
I'd be like the older Spider-Man that they killed for
that new Spider-Man.
Miles Morales origin story,
the funny reason behind that question they were asking
him, like, did they bring you back as an apology
for not casting you as Spider-Man way back in the day.
Brian Michael Bendis created the Miles Morales
Spider-Man after seeing Donald Glover
where the Spider-Man suit on the community TV series,
if you remember, there was all that fan
art featuring Donald Glover as a version of Spider-Man.
Like,
could he be a version of Spider-Man at some point?
So Brian
Michael Bendis was inspired to create Miles Morales.
Spider-Man like, yeah, we could have a Spider-Man.
Who is not Peter Parker.
So essentially Donald Glover in real life
inspired the creation of the Miles Morales character,
which is why it's so important
that you have him in your franchise as a character,
even if it's not as Spider-Man Right now, it is unclear
if Marvel wants to actually do live action.
Miles Morales references during Spider-Man four
because apparently there is a war
going on between Marvel and Sony over
exactly how Spider-Man four is going to go down.
and it turns out it's Sony who apparently wants
to make Spider-Man for another major multiverse movie
with universe ending Consequence is bringing back
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
as main characters in the movie with way more scenes
than they had in Spider-Man No Way Home.
Like they'd be much bigger characters
in the movie in general.
so when Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man teased
that he wanted to fight an alien
after Tobey Maguire,
Tom Holland referenced his venom in Thanos.
Sony was intending on paying that off in Spider-Man
four.
Apparently end, I think most of us agreed
that they'd probably be better off
waiting till Avengers
Secret Wars to give Tom Holland the symbiote
so they could be more comic book accurate
because that's how he got the symbiote originally.
Like why not just do the comics?
but apparently this drama between Marvel and Sony right
now, Kevin Feige wants Spider-Man 4
to be more ground level friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man movie with a brand new Spider-Man
villain from the comics,
and then Kingpin and also Daredevil.
but on the other side of things,
Sony wants the movie to be this huge multiverse
Avengers level film again
with Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
coming back like if you thought The Spider-Man
No Way Home was a big deal.
They want to escalate things even further
I think in Kevin Feige's version
of Spider-Man four, Tobey and Andrew don't come back
until at least Secret Wars.
There might be some Easter eggs in Deadpool three,
like some funny Easter eggs
from their Spider-Man movies, but I don't think
they actually appear on screen until Secret Wars.
Let me know in the comments, though,
if Kevin Feige and Marvel win out with their plan
and they make the smaller street level Spider-Man
four movie with Tom Holland,
do you want them to reference live Action Miles Morales
or do you want them
to just wait till like a future Spider-Man sequel?
like I said, there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Super Bowl trailers.
Be sure to enable alerts on my channels.
You don't miss that.
I'll post that Deadpool three trailer
as soon as it releases.
Click here for all those brand new Deadpool
3 teaser trailers and click here to learn
about all the Andrew Garfield Easter Eggs
inside the Madame Web movie in their plans for that.
Thank you so much for watching.
And we'll see you guys in the next one!